[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Dunja Hayali
schönen guten Abend Sprachbilder sind ja
ein gern genommenes Instrument von
Politikern insbesondere vom
Bundeskanzler Abwehrschirm doppelwumms
zeitenwände ja denn sie sind klangvoll
sie sind eingängig werden deshalb von
vielen Bürgern nicht sofort hinterfragt
und von uns Medien manchmal zu schnell
und zu unkritisch übernommen so wie
heute vor einem Jahr da ist es Olaf
Scholz gelungen die komplexe Veränderung
in der Welt auf ein Wort
herunterzubrechen zeitenwände das war
drei Tage nach Kriegsbeginn und er bekam
viel Applaus dafür auch aus der
Opposition von dort ist der mittlerweile
verheilt aber zurecht Andreas
wir erleben eine Zeitenwende und das
bedeutet die Welt danach ist nicht mehr
dieselbe wie die Welt davor
Zeiten Wände seit genau einem Jahr
dominiert dieser politische Begriff das
Handeln der Bundesregierung der
Bundeshaushalt 2022 wird dieses
Sondervermögen einmalig mit 100
Milliarden Euro ausstatten
Zeiten Wende meint meist die Ausstattung
der Bundeswehr Putins Überfall auf die
Ukraine hat die Frage aufgeworfen was
wäre wenn Deutschland angegriffen wird
wie steht es um die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit wir werden von
nun an Jahr für Jahr mehr als zwei
Prozent des Bruttoinlandsproduktes in
unsere Verteidigung investiert und jetzt
sind wir hoffentlich aufgewacht und ich
sag bewusst nicht wieder einschlafen
weil einige ja schon davon träumen dass
diese Krieg und alles dann im Sommer
wieder vorbei sein wird nein wir haben
eine Dekade an Bedrohungen wir müssen
wieder im militärische Fähigkeiten
investieren und deswegen braucht es auch
mehr als die 100 Milliarden
aufschlagstockung des verteidigungsetats
sonst wird nicht funktionieren
Putins Angriffskrieg hat Lücken bei
Material und Ausrüstung in die
bundeswehrbestände gerissen durch die
Unterstützung der Ukraine
Panzerhaubitzen Raketenwerfer Flugabwehr
zuletzt die Zusage für 18 hochmoderne
Leopard Kampfpanzer das ganze kostet
nicht nur Unmengen Geld sondern muss
auch wieder beschafft werden wir können
nicht der Ukraine helfen nach Kräften
was ich für richtig halte und
gleichzeitig noch vollere Lage haben als
vorher beides beißt sich die
Herausforderung ist jetzt das wieder
zusammenzubringen denn die Zeiten Wände
geht immer einher mit dem 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr was
nichts anderes heißt als 100 Milliarden
mehr an Schulden dieses Geld kommt nicht
dort an wo es ankommen müsste es wird
offensichtlich auch nicht so eingesetzt
wie es geplant ist bislang ist dieses
Geld weder für Munition noch für
Waffensysteme ausgegeben worden
Milliarden für das Militär vor allem in
der SPD tun sich viele damit schwer es
braucht nämlich auch Milliarden für
Wohnungsbau für die Pflege Reform für
Schulen oder die Bekämpfung von
Kinderarmut
für uns ist ganz klar als
Sozialdemokraten das auch die
sozialpolitischen Vorhaben wie
beispielsweise die Kinder Grundsicherung
aber auch die bildungspolitischen
Vorhaben oder die Pflege dass die eben
auch ihre Umsetzung erfahren überhaupt
scheinen noch nicht alle Projekte
innerhalb der Bundesregierung
abgesprochen und ausverhandelt das
riecht nach Streit äußere Sicherheit
auch äußere Stärke gibt es nur mit
inneren Zusammenhalt und inneren
Zusammenhalt den gibt es nur mit guter
Sozialpolitik am Ende des Tages muss das
alles natürlich finanziert werden und
auch die Frage beantwortet werden müssen
wo das Geld herkommt vielleicht durch
noch ein Sondervermögen diesmal mit dem
Schwerpunkt Sozialpolitik interessantes
Thema für die anstehende
koalitionsklausur der Bundesregierung ab
nächsten Sonntag
bleiben also einige Fragen offen die wir
jetzt klären wollen und zwar mit
chakanty aus unserem Hauptstadtstudio
und Abend
die Opposition sagt ja wir haben es
gerade gehört sehr viel versprochen aber
dann doch nicht so viel passiert ist es
wirklich korrekt aber irgendwie
vielleicht auch unfair
also zumindest unter schlägt es ja dass
ein Reformstau von Jahrzehnten der sich
ja bei der Bundeswehr dort angesammelt
hat und der jetzt aufgelöst werden soll
nicht so ganz einfach innerhalb von 12
Monaten zu bearbeiten ist auf der
anderen Seite ist es auch nicht weiter
verwunderlich dass sich die Opposition
hier auf die Bundeswehr und die
versprochenen Neuerungen dort
konzentriert denn das ist zum einen das
größte Projekt das Olaf Scholz mit der
zeitenwände ausgerufen hat und es ist
auch verbunden mit konkreten Zahlen man
kann eben ganz genau schauen wie viel
Geld wird aufgewendet wie viel Geld ist
schon geflossen und an am aktuellen
Stand sieht man eben wie schleppend ist
vorangeht das ist ja so schleppend das
sogar der Koalitionspartner FDP auch
Kritik daran äußert die anderen Punkte
die Olaf Scholz in seiner redete genannt
hat nämlich die Unterstützung der
Ukraine Druck auf Russland durch
Sanktionen die Sicherung der
Energieversorgung und die diplomatischen
Kanäle offen zu halten sind viel
schwerer zu erfassen und zu bewerten
jetzt ein Jahr nach Rede das sind alles
Baustellen die sind abhängig vom
Kriegsverlauf und von der Frage wie
lange läuft der Krieg noch und das ist
natürlich jetzt noch nicht abschließend
zu bewerten alles einen laufender
Prozess ist 100 Milliarden
Sondervermögen die stehen aber fest man
könnte auch sagen Schulden für die
Bundeswehr jedenfalls aber bei der
Zeitenwende geht es schon noch um mehr
ja natürlich der Krieg und die
Verwerfungen die dadurch entstanden sind
die die wirken sich auf sämtliche
Politikfelder hier aus und die große
Aufgabe die die Bundesregierung jetzt
hat es eben zu schauen in welches
Gleichgewicht bringt sie die höheren
Ausgaben für die Verteidigung die schon
beschlossen sind im Verhältnis zu den
anderen Projekten die Sie sich einmal
vorgenommen hat und die allesamt
wahrscheinlich genauso wichtig sind für
Deutschlands Zukunft und nur einige zu
nennen sind da Klimaschutz Bildung und
Infrastruktur also riesen Projekte die
man gemeinsam angehen wollte da muss man
jetzt schauen wie gewichtet man das
alles neu und diese Prioritäten setzt
man Chuck unterlag vielleicht noch ganz
kurz und wenn dann so viel umgesetzt
werden soll irgendwer muss doch aber
auch verzichten ja das ist die ganz
große Frage die die Bundesregierung
jetzt gerade in der aktuellen
haushaltsverhandlung beschäftigt aber
wahrscheinlich auch noch beschäftigen
wird über die gesamte Zeit in der sie
noch miteinander regieren denn am Ende
läuft immer auf die Frage raus nimmt man
mehr Schulden auf oder verzichtet man
das eine ist momentan mit der FDP nicht
zu haben das andere mit den Grünen nicht
und das ist eine Aufgabe und Knoten der
dadurch schlagen werden muss da beneidet
wahrscheinlich nicht einmal die
Opposition gerade die Bundesregierung um
diese Arbeit auch das wohl ein
knotenlöser Charakter war das aus
unserem Hauptstadtstudio danke nach
Berlin
und wir machen weiter mit Entscheidungen
und ihren Folgen die Entscheidung um die
es jetzt geht war der brexit die Folge
war der Austritt des Vereinigten
Königreichs aus der EU drei Jahre ist
das nun her und seitdem gibt es Streit
um das sogenannte
nordirland-protokoll durch den brexit
hätte es zwischen der Republik Irland
Teil der EU und Nordirland nicht mehr
Teil der EU eine feste Grenze mit
Zollkontrollen geben müssen aber das
wollte niemand und sogar bis stattdessen
seit dem brexit eine Zollgrenze im Meer
eine dauerhafte Lösung war aber auch die
nicht und so suchte man seit Jahren nach
einem Kompromiss und der wurde heute
zwischen Großbritannien und der EU
tatsächlich gefunden Elke Petersen
das Lächeln der
eu-kommissionspräsidentin saß heute in
Windsor und half durch den Tag
Dankeschön vor allem den britischen
Premierminister Richie sunak der kämpft
schon lange mit einer besonders heiklen
Tücke des brexit Handels Hindernisse
mitten durchs Königreich mit Nordirland
den Streit darum mit der EU hier zu
beenden das musste heute endlich klappen
die Briten müssen der EU dazu Einblick
in Handelsdaten ermöglichen um
zollbürokratie zu minimieren
der Kompromiss sieht vor das waren nicht
kontrolliert werden die von der
britischen Insel nach Nordirland
geliefert und dort verkauft werden
anders bei Produkten die weiter nach
Irland gehen also in die EU zudem soll
die nordirische Mehrwertsteuer wieder in
London festgesetzt werden der
Europäische Gerichtshof spielt eine
Rolle sollte es zu Streitigkeiten über
Nordirland als Teil des EU Binnenmarkts
kommen außerdem ein Mitspracherecht für
das Regionalparlament in Belfast bei
eu-gesetzes Vorhaben
Winzer Rahmenabkommen so haben sie den
Verhandlungserfolg getauft und verkauft
eine selten gewordene Scham Offensive
zwischen Europa und Großbritannien
ich stehe hier heute weil ich glaube
dass wir Wege gefunden haben die
Unsicherheit und die Herausforderungen
für die Nordiren zu beenden
wenn wir auf die großen gemeinsamen
Herausforderungen schauen ob es der
grausame Ukraine Krieg ist oder der
Kampf gegen den Klimawandel wir haben so
viel gemeinsam wir kämpfen für die
gleichen Werte stehen auf derselben
Seite Schulter an Schultern
die Botschaft wir haben noch ganz andere
Probleme als eine handelsgrenze dann
trennen sich die Wege der beiden Ursula
von der Leyen rauscht weiter nur um die
Ecke ins Schloss zum Tee mit König
Charles als würden sie das neue Windsor
Rahmenabkommen leise feiern
für sonat beginnt der ungemütliche Teil
des Tages im Parlament muss er auch
vielen Skeptikern erklären wie weiter
mit der EU und dem brexit der Dank dafür
an seine Vorgänger verunglückt
es lauern Gefahren für den schönen Deal
von heute etwas von der unionistischen
diopien Nordirlands die dort die
Regierung boykottiert und von den brexit
Hardlinern in Sonax eigener Partei er
hat versprochen dass das Parlament
abstimmen kann in wenigen Tagen da
braucht er wieder so viel Glück wie
heute mit der EU
und mit diesem Kompromiss sollen dann
also insbesondere Zollkontrollen für
warengüter zwischen dem britischen Teil
der irischen Insel und der Republik
Irland die ja zur EU gehört verhindert
werden Außengrenze hin oder her fragen
wir nach bei Gunnar Krüger in Brüssel
auch die einen schönen guten Abend und
ist denn jetzt mit diesem Kompromiss der
brexit in allen Punkten abgearbeitet und
abgewickelt
zumindest machten beide Seiten heute
über den Tag große Hoffnungen darauf und
Sie haben ja auch ganz gute Gründe denn
erstens scheint technisch dieser Deal
nun machbar aus sich der EU lautet der
ja ganz schlicht gibt uns eure Waren
Daten dann verzichten wir auf unsere
Grenzkontrollen die EU sagt sozusagen
die interessieren uns nicht was in einem
Würstchen drin steckt das aus England
nach Nordirland exportiert wird und dort
dann verzerrt wird wir interessieren uns
aber sehr wohl dafür was das für
Wärmepumpen sind zum Beispiel die über
Nordirland nach Irland exportiert werden
die müssen dann EU-Standards entsprechen
und so will man den EU Binnenmarkt
schützen zugleich macht man aber auch
Hoffnung weil man jetzt politisches
Vertrauen geworden hat hier sind
Delegationen zwischen Brüssel und London
über Monate hin und her gereist und
nichts davon ist nach draußen getrunken
ganz anders als bei durch die Sonax
Vorgänger Boris Johnson also man hat da
Vertrauen gefunden und zugleich wissen
eben auch in der Seiten man muss sich
jetzt einiges herrscht Krieg in Europa
und da ist ein Frieden in Nordirland
noch mal umso wertvoller man muss man
will zusammenarbeiten bei wichtigen
Punkten zum Beispiel in der Wissenschaft
aber vor allem natürlich in der
Verteidigung in der Rüstung und da
trifft es sich schlecht wenn man sich
auf der anderen Seite über den Tisch
zieht wenn man zwei pflanzlich
ausdrücken will dann haben sich beide
Seiten heute geeinigt es ging ihnen
einmal nicht um die Wurst sondern um
gemeinsame europäische Werte schönes
Bild von Gunnar Krüger vielen herzlichen
Dank für die Einschätzung nach Brüssel
ja Menschenrechtsverletzungen die gibt
es ja in vielen Ländern Heinz aber in
einem Land besonders das sticht
jedenfalls etwas heraus
sieht im russischen Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine die derzeit massivsten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen tot
Zerstörung und Vertreibung sein die
folgen sagte gotisch in einer Rede vor
dem Menschenrechtsrat der UN in Genf
bundesaußenministerin bärburg ging dort
in ihrer Rede auf Berichte über
systematische Verschleppungen
ukrainischer Kinder nach Russland ein
was könnte abscheulicher sein sagte
bärbock und erklärte man werde nicht
ruhen bis jedes einzelne Kind wieder zu
Hause ist
und bärbock ging auch auf die
katastrophale humanitäre Lage im
Bürgerkriegsland Jemen ein und sagte aus
Deutschland Hilfe in Höhe von 120
Millionen Euro zu die Vereinten Nationen
baten auf einer internationalen
Geberkonferenz um Unterstützung für die
Menschen im Jemen insgesamt kamen rund
1,2 Milliarden Euro zusammen nötig ist
nach UN-Angaben etwa das Vierfache im
Jemen brauchen 21 Millionen Menschen und
damit etwa zwei Drittel der Bevölkerung
Hilfe Nahrung Trinkwasser und
medizinische Versorgung zurzeit gibt es
eine brüchige Waffenruhe zwischen den
Regierungstruppen und den husäre bellen
nach Berlin und zur Wiederholungswahl
für das Abgeordnetenhaus da steht jetzt
das amtliche Endergebnis fest hinter dem
Wahlsieger CDU bleibt die SPD auf Platz
2 allerdings schrumpfte der knappe
Vorsprung auf die Grünen von 105 Stimmen
auf nur noch 53 Stimmen wer die
Hauptstadt künftig regiert ist noch
nicht klar
der Vorsitzende der katholischen
deutschen Bischofskonferenz Betzingen
hat trotz Differenzen mit dem Vatikan
den reformwellen der Bischöfe betont der
Auftakt der Frühjahrsvollversammlung der
Bischöfe wurde von Spannungen mit dem
Vatikan überschattet der unter anderem
den geplanten Synodalen Rat aus
Klerikern und Laien ablehnt dieser
Kritik hatten sich auch einige Bischöfe
angeschlossen in der kommenden Woche
soll der Reformkurs auf der letzten
synodalversammlung in Frankfurt
beschlossen werden
was bringen Verbote reizen sie ein erst
recht die Dinge zu tun zu sehen zu
konsumieren auszuprobieren die einem
verboten werden und was bringt es wenn
politisch Verantwortliche es verbieten
das wird sich zeigen denn
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister Özdemir
will künftig Werbung für zum Beispiel
Chips Schokolade und andere Dickmacher
für Kinder zumindest mal einschränken im
Zuge dessen das rund 15 Prozent 15
Prozent der drei bis 17-Jährigen hier
bei uns übergewichtig sind mag das
vielleicht eine gute Idee sein man fragt
sich bloß warum Werbung im Rahmen der
Fußball EM im nächsten Jahr davon nicht
betroffen sein sollen mindestens ein
großer Sponsor dürfte sich darüber
freuen Ritter Buchholz
es kam ziemlich überraschend erst am
Morgen lud der Minister zur
Pressekonferenz das Vorhaben wirkt
Sprengstoff denn er möchte ein
Werbeverbot von 6 bis 23 Uhr für
Produkte mit zu viel Zucker Salz oder
Fett die gezielt Kinder ansprechen sein
Vorschlag eine Kampfansage an die
Industrie
gesetzlichen Regelungen werden immer da
nötig wo freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtungen scheitern fakt ist
die bisherigen freiwilligen
Selbstverpflichtungen haben bei Schutz
der Kinder nachweislich versagt
nachweislich sind deutsche Kinder zu
dick der Grund viele bewegen sich zu
wenig und essen das falsche nur wie
lässt es sich ändern ist es die
Verantwortung der Eltern nicht nur mein
Mediziner und
Verbraucherorganisationen und loben den
Minister
sind ein Meilenstein im Kampf gegen
federnierungen Übergewicht er nimmt
endlich die Lebensmittelindustrie in
eine Pflicht also macht Schluss mit dem
Prinzip der Freiwilligkeit dass die
Bundesregierung jahrelang vorgelebt hat
die werbewirtschaften nennt die Vorgaben
drastisch sie würden nicht zu weniger
übergewichtigen Kindern führen Vorwurf
an die Politik die Hebel die ist wert
sind umgelegt zu werden die groß und
bedeutsam sind Stichwort
Ernährungsbildung Stichwort
Bewegungsförderung wir sind in einer
befinden uns in der sitzenden
Gesellschaft gerade auch bei Kindern und
schließlich dann auch das Angebot
ausgewogener Ernährung insbesondere in
Kitas und Schulen diese Hebel werden
nicht umgelegt überrascht war heute auch
die FDP sie haben im Koalitionsvertrag
für eine Änderung gestimmt aber so habe
der Vorschlag keine Ampel Mehrheit ich
bin immer dafür dass Eigenverantwortung
in der Politik eine große Rolle spielt
Verbote
bringen an der Stelle aus meiner Sicht
nichts
Zündstoff für die Ampel nun muss der
Entwurf abgestimmt werden das kann
dauern deshalb sind langfristige
Verträge wie beim Fußball Sponsoring
nicht betroffen erst einmal
natürlich auch einen harten Kampf KI
zwei Buchstaben die unsere Welt
verändern künstliche Intelligenz sie
soll erleichtern unterstützen
automatisieren KI kann Fortschritt
bedeuten aber auch angsterzeugen zum
Beispiel wenn es um Arbeitsplätze
Überwachung oder ähnliches geht immer
wieder wird deshalb auch betont dass
diese digitale Transformation schon auch
einen Zusammenspiel zwischen Mensch und
Maschine sein soll insbesondere im
Bereich der Medizin wird das auch immer
wieder bewiesen Sven Regen mit einem
Beispiel aus der Neurologie das Leben
retten kann
dr Nils schweingruber möchte in die
Zukunft schauen am liebsten 24 Stunden
der Intensivmediziner wüsste dann wann
der Hirndruck bei seinen Patienten mit
einem Schädelhirntrauma steigt er und
sein Team fütterten deshalb eine
künstliche Intelligenz mit mehr als 12
Millionen Patientendaten
das tolle ja bei maschinellen lernen ist
dass wir theoretisch ja sogar die ganze
Vergangenheit des Patienten auf der
Intensivstation nutzen können um die
Zukunft vorherzusagen der Anstieg des
Hirndrucks nach einer schweren
Verletzung am Schädel ist für das Ärzte
und Pflegeteam eine große
Herausforderung oft ist ein kritischer
Punkt bereits erreicht bevor helfende
Medikamente wirken die künstliche
Intelligenz kann mathematisch in die
Zukunft sehen gibt also eine Prognose ab
bis hierhin ist die Analyse Karte und
ich weiß dass es jetzt langsam hier in
die falsche Richtung geht und gegen 17
Uhr wäre der Druck dann zu hoch
also kann ich jetzt schon gegensteuern
und kann gucken dass die Kurve nachher
so aussieht gerade in Zeiten von
Personalknappheit an den Kliniken
könnten solche Assistenzsysteme eine
große Unterstützung sein und mangelnde
oder eine zu geringe Erfahrung auf den
Stationen ausgleichen
mit diesem maschinellen lernen kann ich
natürlich simulieren dass man am Ende
von hunderttausenden von Patienten diese
Erfahrungen sammelt in einen Topf daraus
ein Algorithmus macht und der kann dann
auch dem oder der Assistentin mit zwei
Jahren Erfahrungen nachts eine Warnung
geben und sagen achtung da geht es
wahrscheinlich in einer Stunde in die
falsche Richtung das ist der große
benefit die Software ist bereits an
einem Punkt an dem die Prognosen relativ
verlässlich sind das Team am
Universitätsklinikum arbeitet noch an
der grafischen Umsetzung noch offen ist
ob das KI Prognose Tool nicht nur Alarm
schlägt sondern am Ende auch konkrete
Handlungen anzeigt man kann sich auch
andersrum vorstellen der macht mir ein
Vorschlag und sagt stell mal die
Beatmung so hoch und mach mal irgendwie
in manitol oder so Infusion so aber
sowas sind wir noch lange nicht und das
hat natürlich auch eine gewisse Brisanz
rechtlich wer trägt die Verantwortung
wenn dieser Vorschlag völlig daneben
geht
ja im Moment ist es auch relativ klar
natürlich wird auch das zum
Assistenzsystems beeinflussen unsere
Entscheidungen ist also auch total es
auch rechtsrelevant aber die
Entscheidung am Ende ist eine ärztliche
Entscheidung die KI muss im
Alltagsbetrieb ihre Zuverlässigkeit
beweisen sollten die Prognosen aber
dauerhaft verlässlich sein hätten die
Mediziner ein effektives Frühwarnsystem
für hirntrauma Patienten weitere
Anwendungsbereiche sollen folgen
wenigen Monaten da war noch nicht so
richtig klar wie es um die
Wirtschaftsleistung Deutschlands
bestellt sein wird heizt da war ja von
massiver Inflation die Rede aber der was
tun gegen steigende Preise gegen hohe
Inflation und darauf Antworten zu finden
haben Bundesregierung Gewerkschaften und
Arbeitgeber seit dem vergangenen Jahr in
den sogenannten konzertierten Aktion
beraten und die können uns zunächst
ausgesetzt werden erklärt die Regierung
die beschlossenen Maßnahmen wir wirkten
die Wirtschaftsentwicklung in
Deutschland habe sich in den letzten
Monaten stabilisiert Frank Bethmann wie
ist denn also die Lage ja der Eindruck
der sich aufdringt alles nur noch halb
so schlimm die Preise steigen nicht mehr
ganz so stark die Lieferprobleme nebenan
wie wir ja gerade heute wieder hören
konnten davor waren doch viele Fachleute
nach wie vor ist die Lage ernste stimmt
die Inflationsraten waren schon mal
höher doch auch die Bundesregierung
erwartet für dieses Jahr immer noch
einen Preisauftrieb von sechs Prozent
für Vize Regierungssprecher Wolfgang
Büchner aber stimmt der generelle Trend
wir sind gut durch diesen Winter
gekommen wir sind auch gute dieses Jahr
gestartet und von daher
sehen wir jetzt die Situation so dass
man diese aussetzen kann dass wir die
konzertifikation aussetzen heißt nicht
dass alle Probleme verschwunden sind
keineswegs die Betriebe klagen die
Energiepreise sind im internationalen
Vergleich noch viel zu hoch und immer
teurer wird das benötigte Personal
Fachkräfte sind in vielen Branchen und
Bereichen Mangelware Gewerkschaften
verhandeln nach Jahren der Zurückhaltung
mit harten Bandagen hohe Lohnabschlüsse
aber drohen die Inflation wieder
anzufachen fast folgerichtig warnt die
Bank für internationalen
Zahlungsausgleich die gerne auch als
Bank der Zentralbanken bezeichnet wird
vor allzu großen Übermut man habe die
Inflation noch längst nicht wieder im
Griff Frank Wittmann vielen Dank
in Nordrhein-Westfalen hat es heute in
vielen Bereichen des öffentlichen Lebens
waren Streiks gegeben betroffen waren
unter anderem Kitas
Ämter sowie der nah und Flugverkehr
hunderte Flüge vielen an den Airports
Köln Bonn und Düsseldorf aus mehrere
Gewerkschaften hatten zu den Ausständen
aufgerufen nachdem die Tarifgespräche
für die Beschäftigten im öffentlichen
Dienst in der vergangenen Woche ohne
Einigung geblieben waren
in der vergangenen Nacht war ein in
unseren Breiten seltenes Naturphänomen
zu bestaunen grünliche und rötliche
Polarlichter strahlten für etwa eine
Stunde am Himmel vor allem im Norden
Deutschlands aber auch über der Küste
der Niederlande verantwortlich für das
leuchtend sind elektrisch geladene
Teilchen die bei Sonnenstürmen
fortgeschleudert werden und in die
Erdatmosphäre eintreten auch in der
kommenden Nacht könnte es wieder
Polarlichter geben
also Augen auf sagt ihnen der Name
marinus von der Lübbe etwas der
niederländische Kommunist soll heute
genau von 90 Jahren den Reichstag in
Brand gesteckt haben ob er es alleine
war oder nicht darüber wird bis heute
diskutiert versteht für die
Nationalsozialisten war der Brand im
Grunde ein Geschenk vielleicht sogar ein
selbstgemachtes jedenfalls trat am
folgenden Tag die Notverordnung zum
Schutz von Volk und Staats in Kraft und
setzte damit die politischen Grundrechte
außer Kraft
über ein Rätsel über einen 90 Jahre
altes Rätsel das endlich gelüftet werden
soll
der Südfriedhof in Leipzig eine kleine
Gedenkfeier für Marinus van der Lübbe
Streichhölzer für einen Brandstifter in
den Schachteln Texte des Hingerichteten
Niederländers vor einem Monat wurde sein
Grab geöffnet übrigens nicht zum ersten
Mal völlig unbekannt bereits in der DDR
wurde sein Deichmann exponiert wir
wissen dass es 1953 eine heimliche
grabesöffnung gab wir wissen aber nicht
was da weiter passiert ist einmal mehr
das große Rätselraten um den
Maurerlehrling marinus von der Lippe
erstes Ergebnis der Gerichtsmedizin er
konnte zweifelsfrei identifiziert werden
für Auto Uwe kann der holländische links
Anarchist unmöglich allein den Reichstag
angezündet haben für ihn waren es die
Nazis
Einzeltäter geht deshalb nicht weil
Marius von der Lunge im Reichstag keine
halbe Stunde Zeit hatte dort
herumgelaufen ist mit kohlenentzündung
diese Kuppel ist regelrecht in die Luft
geflogen wer legte das Feuer seit
Jahrzehnten wird unter Historikern
gestritten in der nachkriegsbundes
Republik hatte sich die
alleintäter-these durchgesetzt der
24-Jährige Lübbe hatte die Tat gestanden
aus Protest gegen Hitler es steht ja
ganz außer Zweifel dass er im Reichstag
gezündet hat er hatte vorher versucht
das Neuköllner Wohlfahrtsamt anzustecken
das Berliner Schloss das Berliner
Rathaus der Mann war also da der 27
Februar 33 ist ein eiskalter Wintertag
gegen 21:05 Uhr später klar Vorhänge
brennen genau um
21:27 Uhr verwandelt sich der Plenarsaal
in ein Flammen mir vermutlich Folge eine
rauchgasexplosion
von der Löwe wird im Reichstag
festgenommen tatsächlich gibt es offene
Fragen der Holländer war zu 80%
sehbehindert und soll mit
kohleanzündernden Brand entfacht haben
so kühl präsentiert in seinem Buch eine
Reihe von Indizien die für seine Nazi
diese sprechen zum Beispiel der
Augenzeuge Hans weiß der Reporter war
vor Ort die 98-Jährige Rot Weiß erinnert
sich wie er Männer aus dem Reichstag
kommen sah sie waren gekleidet wie
arbeite in einem guten Mantel und mit
Mützen und sind aber im Schritt gelaufen
auf einen Lastwagen drauf gesprungen und
wurden sofort weggefahren
während die Trümmer noch rauchen macht
Hitler die Kommunisten für den Brand
verantwortlich ab jetzt gebe es kein
Erbarmen mehr der Brände Reichstag wird
zum Vernal für den Untergang der
Demokratie
profitiert haben aber am Ende natürlich
nur die Nazis davon und die anderen
waren von der Lippes letzte Worte vor
der Enthauptung jetzt werden in Leipzig
knochenproben untersucht ob er beim
Prozess unter Drogen stand quasi
ruhiggestellt worden ist ein weiteres
bizarres Puzzle bei der Streitfrage wer
hat den Reichstag angezündet
und das war's von uns für heute morgen
übernimmt hier wieder Marietta aber
Heinz bleibt ja und um 23:35 Uhr gibt's
heute schon mal Update wir können Gause
machen sie es gut wo auch immer sie sind
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend der meteorologische Winter
besteht ja aus den Monaten Dezember
Januar und Februar und geht damit morgen
zu Ende es ist der zwölfte zu warme
Winter in Folge er ist 2,7 Grad wärmer
in Deutschland Mittel als im
vieljährigen klimatologischen Mittel der
Jahre 1961 bis 1990 zu erwarten gewesen
wäre und auch wenn es jetzt heute und
morgen relativ kühl ist das wird nichts
mehr ändern an dieser Bilanz das Wetter
ist ziemlich eingefahren zwischen dem
Hoch hier über Großbritannien dem
hochhasel und dem Tief Zakaria über dem
westlichen Mittelmeer bleibt das Wetter
bei uns in den nächsten Tagen sehr ruhig
zum Teil kühl zum Teil auch mit
Wolkenfeldern heute Nacht kannst
vielleicht noch mal eine Schneeflocke
geben hier auf der Schwäbischen Alb oder
auch im Schwarzwald sonst ist es häufig
klar wenn sie nach dem Polarlichtern
Ausschau halten wollen nördlich der
Mittelgebirge sieht das ganz gut aus nur
nicht im äußersten Norden da stören
Nebel Dunst und einige Wolkenfelder wie
auch im Osten die Temperaturen sinken
auf zwei Grad an der Nordsee und bis -10
oder -11 Grad in den östlichen
Mittelgebirgen unterm Alpenrand und
morgen liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
zwischen 0 Grad hier im Osten und sieben
Grad am Rhein oder auch in Nordfriesland
ähnlich wie heute gibt's auch morgen
viel Sonnenschein nur kleine Quellwolken
ähnlich sieht's dann auch zu
meteorologischen Frühlingsbeginn am
Mittwoch und Donnerstag aus am Freitag
dreht der Wind dann auf Nordwest bis
bald